sin ha concluido esta mañana la asamblea
nacional popular la segunda celebrada en
la era del coronavirus esta vez no ha
sido necesario retrasar la como el
pasado año pero sí se ha cortado a una
semana respecto a las dos acostumbradas
y se han tomado todo tipo de medidas de
precaución se ha vacunado a los tres mil
delegados llegados desde todo el país
hasta aquí el gran palacio del pueblo y
las medidas se han extendido a los pocos
periodistas que hemos conseguido este
año la invitación nos han hecho un test
de madrugada y hemos pasado la noche en
un hotel hasta recibir el resultado y
ser conocidos a la plaza de tiananmen la
jornada en una ofrecido sorpresas como
es habitual en un parlamento que se
limite a sellar todas las propuestas del
ejecutivo ha salido adelante la
anunciada reforma electoral de hong kong
que dificultará aún más el acceso de la
oposición al parlamento de la excolonia
y también se ha aprobado el plan
quinquenal que subraya la necesidad de
aumentar el consumo interno y la
autosuficiencia tecnológica dos asuntos
en los que los avances son más lentos de
lo que esperaba a pekín